hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to show you how to use elliot waves
theory and fibonacci techniques applied
to the cryptocurrencies so we're gonna
have a look at the bitcoin
ad cardano ethereum and dutch kind so
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so the first thing i would
like to do is to go with you through the
elliot wave book that was written by
frost and presta so we're gonna go
through this together and actually this
is a book that has 118 pages so you can
just find it by googling it on google
and it's free so you can all have a look
at this and i did already uh the job for
you guys i found the interesting
information that we are going to use
during this course all right so first
information that is very important is
this one okay so page 73 of this book so
basically you have some ratios that are
given by fibonacci to the elliot waves
right so that's why it's very good to
combine those two together and once you
know one plus three so you have three
different situations third wave
extension fifth wave extension first
wave extension i don't see this one very
often almost never i usually see this
one
or this one okay
so either the one in the middle or the
one here on the right or left i mean
those two are a sum up of those three so
what you need to remember is that once
you know one plus three basically you
can deduce the fifth wave that is going
to be equal to 0.618 times the uh one
plus three in this situation you just
divide 0.618 by 0.38
and 1.618 in this situation sorry you
divide 38.2 by 61.8 and if you divide
61.8 by 28.2 and it gives you 1.618 so
what you need to remember a lot of
figures have been uh given here what you
only need to remember is that the fifth
wave is equal to 0.618 or 1.618 times
one plus three i noticed that sometimes
we have a one-to-one relationship as
well which is not in the book but what i
give you and here page 79 here you have
even more information and i'm going to
show you right now how to use it on the
cryptocurrency market how you can
actually use this information because
fibonacci trading is something that you
know people talk about and nobody really
knows what to do it's because you
absolutely need to associate it with
earlier to a theory otherwise you don't
really know what to do and once you've
done that you're gonna see that
basically fibonacci retracement is going
to be used to enter on pullbacks in a
given trend so you first need to
identify a trend like we're having right
now for cryptocurrency we are definitely
starting a new trend so we are in the
first wave i'm going to show you this
very soon and we are wondering where the
second wave could go and fibonacci is
telling you the answer all right so here
elliot says that usually the second wave
is correcting you can see here two to
the 0.618
percent retracement of the first wave
okay so this is giving you a first
information and i'm gonna apply this to
the cryptocurrency right now because we
are waiting for a second wave then you
also know that
once you're going to complete the third
wave you can have a force wave pullback
again to enter for fifth wave so this is
rather the situation we have on tesla we
have a mara you have we have on many
stocks and if you want to enter this
pool back then it's usually more shallow
and it only goes to the 38
let me zoom in here to the 38.2 percent
all right so two things you need to
remember second way is like to go to the
0.618 so quite deep corrections and
force wave they are more shallow they
like to go to the 38.2 retracement now
from my experience what i have noticed
is that second wave sometimes are
shallow too and i personally start to
buy at the 50 retracement 50 61.8 and i
stop everything below the 78.6 percent
and for four slaves i have noticed that
they sometimes go further so basically
it really depends where you have your
support levels because fibonacci is
going to give you areas of support and
then depending on where you have your
real supports or resistance that have
been drawn using trend lines and using
past elliot wave countings then you're
going to be able to you know select
better the type of retracement that
you're probably gonna have so
four things to remember fifth wave so
and here basically have all the
information so just remember this chart
page 79 fifth wave they like to go to
1.618 or 0.618 of one plus three
so this is the information happening
here false wave they like to go to the
thirty eight point two percent of uh
only the third wave okay and second wave
they like to go to the 61.8 percent of
first wave now we are gonna keep this in
mind and apply all of this to the
cryptocurrency market let's get into it
all right so first let's start with the
king bitcoin so very quickly what i'm
gonna try to do here is to show you how
to use elliot wave principle that says
that moves up developing five waves and
moves down developing three waves and
fibonacci associated to elliot wave so
this is actually very advanced but i'm
just gonna keep it very simple here i'm
not gonna cover all the possible cases
i'm just gonna show you what usually is
working so let's have a look at bitcoin
i'm on a daily time frame i'm having the
move started in march 20 alright so we
had here a first move up in five waves
then a correction very shallow third
move up correction shallow as well but a
bit deeper and the fifth wave the fifth
wave is here it's this one one two three
four five it finished in a wedge pattern
with a bearish divergence with magdy all
right market making high highs the macd
going lower so this is a sign of
weakness after which we had this strong
correction now this correction seems to
be over wxy that is here it was a bit
longer than expected in time i mean not
in spot we didn't go deeper than 28k
which is the bottom of the force which
is something you need to keep in mind
top of the third bottom of the force
preceding waves is the usual level of
the correction after a wave is complete
so here it was 42 and 28 we went to 28
but we stayed there a bit longer then we
had this here breakout we had an early
breakout at 32 000
that i gave you guys you can go check
the video i posted i know three weeks
ago or something like this then we had
the second breakout that was the
confirmation that this correction is
over and right now guys it's very
interesting so i had a target at 48
000 for this first wave so i'm
struggling here a bit if this first wave
is finished or not because the little
game we're doing here to try to
anticipate when the pullback is going to
come and how deep it's going to be to
enter so to know where this first wave
might be going i zoomed in i'm on the
forest time frame and here for the first
thing i'm doing is that i'm putting my
resistance level so here you can see i
have a high here i have a high so i have
a resistance at 51 500 and another one
at 59 000. i had one as well below
that's why i gave you this
around 49k something like this but
whatever so right now what is happening
we don't have enough information to
predict accurately what is going to be
the top of this first wave what we're
going to say is that it's very likely to
be one of those resistance levels so
either 51 500 or
59
500. now the other thing we can do is
try to use elliot wave inside this wave
but when you zoom in in those smaller
timeframes elliott wave is not easy to
use actually but i'm still gonna try
here so this could be one two three four
and five so maybe
this is a valid counting
this would be a typical impulse the
third wave would be a bit short here so
for example what is interesting to see
is because the third wave can't be the
shortest so here we go from 37 to 48 so
11 000 so the fifth wave must be shorter
so 11 000 plus 44 it's 55 000. so if
this counting is to be correct we cannot
go above 55 000 okay so this is the
first information we can use but what is
interesting here so to be very honest i
i have no clue where the top would be my
guess would be
around the 51 500 level now that we have
broken the 48 thousand
but i believe that there's going to be a
second wave pullback coming okay
and then you can use fibonacci to kind
of build your different scenarios and
see where this feedback could come the
first thing is that here we're having a
support level at 42 000. you remember
where this level is coming from it was
the top of the third here it was the
rebound that we had in march 21. we had
also some reactions in the very recent
past here and very even in the most
recent past and this could have been
used as a pullback level to enter a
position and i gave you this as well
guys on my discord so here the situation
is like this we are what in what seems
to be a wedge pattern here in yellow so
if we break
this level so around 47 500 we might
have a smooth re-test and then go over
and the first thing i want to show you
is that here we're having this bearish
divergence you can see the macd making
low highs and the market making higher
highs okay so this is a bearish
divergence so
this information combined with the 51
500 resistance level combined with valid
uh elliot wave counting is telling me
that this is my preferred scenario if
this scenario happens usually second
waves they like to retrace to the 50 or
61.8 percent retracement so let's
imagine we go to 51 500 then the 50 and
61.8 retracement would be between 37 500
and 40 500 so this is of course a nice
level to buy if we go there and if you
have a more shallow correction we would
still go to the 43 000 here so i guess
that the 42 500 might be reached in this
situation so if we go to 51 500 we still
would have pulled back around mid sap
october around 42 500 this is the first
information now let's imagine we go
lower
so this is again
how you can use fibs because combined
with elliot you know that the second
wave would probably retrace at least
28.2 at least and usually it's more so
imagine we go to 59 000 that this market
is very bullish which is very possible
that's why as long as we stay in the
switch pattern if you are wrong i would
not sell i would just i would give you
the chance to go higher because we might
go to 59 000 if you go to 59 000 of
course it's time to take some profits to
reload lower but imagine we go there
then the 38.2 percent would still be
lower than today's level right so that's
why for me no rush
38.2 which is the minimum retracement
level would be at 47
800
so then it might be the first level you
want to buy if we go to 59 000 before
and the 50 and 61.8 are the more usual
levels between forty thousand and forty
four thousand so in most of my scenarios
either we go to fifty one thousand five
hundred or to fifty nine thousand but in
both cases we are going to have a
pullback around the forty forty two
thousand level
in mid september after which
if this is correct we would have a third
wave starting right and this third wave
once again we are not sure right now
that this is correct but this looks very
like nice to me so if this happens the
third wave would probably go to the to
the 100 000 level then pull back and
then 130 why those levels same technique
as usual guys once you have one plus
three you can apply fibonacci
projections this time okay
so i'm showing you here how to use fibs
so you go to the bottom of the first
wave to the top of the third so you take
one plus three and you apply to the
bottom of the force and the 1.618 which
is 130 000
is the level we would probably go for
the end of the fifth wave so this is my
target for 2022. i'm not sure when maybe
you know march or june something like
this but so so but i do believe we would
go there so we are going to have two
opportunities to enter this move second
uh corrective wave and force corrective
wave all right so two pullbacks and once
again i repeat the first pullback should
happen mid-sep october and should go to
the 40 42 000 area even maybe below so
we're gonna keep an eye on this
now let's check ada cardano so now i
have the good ticker last time i took
the wrong one so here it's probably
gonna follow the bitcoin in terms of
trend and in terms of level here so one
two three four five same thing and i
measure one plus three applied to the
bottom of the force and it gives me a
projection that is at 3.8 so i still
have some room here for this fifth wave
this is the only information we can have
here we don't have any high in the past
data that can help us to build some
resistance so the only thing we have is
that the 1.618 would probably be
resistance we also know that sometimes
the fifth wave likes to be a one to one
ratio to the one to three so this would
give us three as a target so this is the
only information i can give you here and
once again i think that as long as the
bitcoin would keep going higher all the
cryptocurrency would follow the move now
ethereum what do we have so this one is
interesting so we have here this massive
move up then correction just like the
bitcoin and now we are starting to go
higher so we can see that the 42 000
equivalent of the bitcoin is here 2900
roughly so i believe we would go back
there we can see that we have this same
bearish divergence even more clearly
here on the ethereum which shows
weakness so to me we have two weaknesses
already coming from the two major
cryptocurrencies so watch out there
could be a pullback coming soon in terms
of levels the next resistance is at 3575
exactly and if i try to do some angular
12 counting inside this one two
three
four and five maybe something like this
you see so this would make sense to me
it's basically you know a bit the same
counting as for the bitcoin and i guess
we would have a pullback to the
2900 level which would be a nice
opportunity so let's measure in terms of
fibs
even maybe deeper guys all right this is
a minimum 2 900 is the minimum level we
would retrace to i would personally
enter on the 50 and 61.8 retracement so
lower around the 2600 level 2500 level
okay this is to me a nice level to buy
on the ethereum but once again you know
sometimes the corrections are more
shallow and they only go to the 38.2 so
if you really don't want to miss the
move up 38.2 is the level that can be
used to set up your buying and orders
and in terms of target here guys it's
pretty much the same thing so we have a
very nice fifth wave to come okay
then
next one guys the dodge coin i know you
like this one so here it is
what do we have here so i check first on
the flowers i see one two three four so
we're on the first corrective wave that
is uh seems to be a big triangle all
right that is here and right now we have
started the fifth wave okay so first
thing let's measure use fibonacci
projections
you measure from one to the top the
bottom of the one to the bottom of the
the top of the third you applied to the
bottom of the force and this gives you
1.35 all right so this is my target for
dodge coin in 2022
in terms of level what do we have here
let me zoom in little bits
okay
so we are here in this first
move up
okay just like the other
cryptocurrencies so one two three so it
looks to me
like here we are missing clearly one
wave which is not the case on bitcoin
and ethereum all right the dutch coin
has more room on the upside so maybe if
the other two just keep grinding a bit
higher dutch coin might actually uh make
some nice move up all right
because i think that dutch can can go to
43 000 for the top of the first wave
let's apply here same one plus three you
measure bottom of the force
okay so this is giving you
here as the third wave is extended we're
gonna have maybe some lower ratios
it's not helping that much it's not
matching any level here you know i would
say 40 the 0.618 is the usual one either
you go to the 1.618 if the fifth wave is
extended if the third wave is extended
or the first wave is extended then you
usually go to the 0.618 so just keep
those levels in mind so here it would be
0.4 for the top of the first
why not this could make sense
so let's see but definitely if the dodge
breaks 0.32 here this trend line we
would have probably a fifth wave of the
first coming here with like a nice 25
percent move up so to me there is a nice
opportunity here and then same thing
guys we'll probably have this pullback
so once again if i
would need to give you a level to enter
on the dodge so let's imagine we go i
don't know to half of it
maybe here
same thing guys around
you know between 25 and 30
would be so right now we are 2d one so
you know right now it's not that bad
guys okay because if we go higher then
we correct actually we're not gonna be
much lower than uh today's level so on
the dodge coin i think that right now is
actually a nice buying opportunity to
play uh this fifth wave and if there is
a pullback you can still increase your
position so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video i hope i managed
to explain how to combine elliot wave
countings all right one two three four
five abc with fibonacci retracements
that can help you to identify at which
level the putback might go and fibonacci
projections that can help you to find
some target for fifth waves so that's it
for me in if you did enjoy this video
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys